la veuve de main aux condamnés à mort
avec un sursis de deux ans le conducteur
d'un train de banlieue tué par un bloc
de béton les otages libérés dans une
heure ils retrouvent leurs familles aux
états unis frida mairie grande course
petite yaris
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir la veuve
de mao tsé toung madame chiang ching a
été condamné à mort avec un sursis de
deux ans
patrick clément qui rentre de pékin nous
explique ce que signifie ce verdict et
sous quelles conditions la condamner
pourrait sauver sa tête pour la lecture
du verdict comme pour l'ouverture du
procès les dix accusés sont de nouveau
réunis et militaires d'un côté la bande
des quatre de l'autre
mais regardez bien regarder au centre de
l'écran cet homme qui n'arrive pas à
placer son écouteurs il a 76 ans il
était à la tête de l'armée chinoise il
ya quelques années
malade le corno non plus ses gestes il
est paniquée à l'idée de ne pouvoir
entendre le détail de sa peine le procès
aura duré deux mois et 5 jours
il s'achève donc aujourd'hui 25 janvier
il va s'achever au moment où le
président de la cour va demander aux
accusés de se lever pour écouter le
verdict
intel 1
et puis de sa voix traînante le
président va annoncer les unes après les
autres les raisons pour lesquelles les
dix accusés sont aujourd'hui réunies
devant la cour spéciale de pékin enfin
il va passer à la lecture des
condamnations en commençant partir de
chine elle est condamnée à mort avec
deux ans de sursis
elle lui répond vive la révolution avec
une violence inouïe on lui met les
menottes est elle si dangereuse même
procédé pour tubes charles et même
condamnation
mais pourquoi tant d'acharnement comme
entre eux qu'ils se déforme les deux
autres membres de la bande des quatre
sont condamnés l'un à 20 ans de prison
l'autre perpétuité les condamnations
prononcées par la cour spéciale ne sont
pas susceptibles d'appel
chongqing est donc condamné à mort avec
deux ans de sursis aux yeux de la loi et
selon la terminologie officielle
changxing peut échapper à la mort si au
bout de deux ans elle se conduit bien
chongqing peut échapper à la mort si
elle accepte de se repentir alors d'une
part en fonction de tout ce que nous
avons vu pendant ce procès en fonction
de tout son attitude faite de fierté de
courage il est fort peu probable que
chongqing comme le dit la loi accepte de
se repentir
d'autre part si l'équipe gouvernementale
est toujours la même à pékin dans deux
ans il est difficilement imaginable que
cette équipe évite la mort à cianci
alors pourquoi dnc au ping ne l'at il
pas condamné à mort tout court
eh bien peut-être parce que le
gouvernement chinois n'en a pas les
moyens
l'avant dernière séance de ce procès
date du 29 décembre 80 nous sommes le 25
janvier 80 il aura donc fallu presque un
mois pour rendre publique cette décision
un mois pendant lequel les hauts
dirigeants se sont réunion se crée un
mois pendant lequel les différentes
factions se sont opposés pour aboutir à
cette condamnation qui vraiment ne
cessera de nous étonner
pendant deux ans chongqing du fond de sa
cellule va représenter leurs proches
vivants va représenter un empoisonnement
constant pour ses dirigeants chinois qui
n'ont pas réussi leur exorcisme qui
n'ont pas réussi à faire disparaître par
une seule balle de revolver le mythe de
celui qui les inventent à tous note
c'est tout à l'évidence ce n'était pas
si facile
la direction de l'information et
l'équipe de la rédaction d'antenne 2
prépare ta question de temps spéciale
consacrée
changing avec des documents
exceptionnels l'émission sera diffusée
très prochainement
l'avion du gouvernement américain qui
ramène les otages libérés doit arriver à
la base militaire de stewards près de
new york d'ici une petite heure après
une escale technique me verront en
irlande
il avait décollé de wiesbaden peu avant
midi médecin personnel médical américain
habitant en allemagne
un millier de personnes étaient là des
lots pour sabler ces hommes qui en 444
jours de détention en iran sont devenus
les héros de toute la nation américaine
selon les témoins il était en excellente
condition physique après ce séjour de
quatre jours de décompression à
l'hôpital américain de wiesbaden ce qui
était militaire à l'ambassade américaine
de terrain avait déjà remis leurs
uniformes les autres regardaient le parc
à qu'on leur avait donné à leur retour
dieu pour tous à musique a joué rubans
jaunes la chanson qui est devenu le
symbole de leur détention
et qui dit accroche un ruban jaune à son
arbre si tu m'aimes encore escale
technique disait en irlande où le
président de la république est venu les
saluer à l'aéroport après leur arrivée
tout à l'heure à la base de stewart ils
auront 24 heures de séjour dit privé ou
embrasser leur famille puis mardi à new
york
on le réservera un accueil annoncé comme
sans précédent avec claude gaignierre
nous allons vendre maintenant visite à
la famille d'un otage pierre temps le
retour pour eux car ces quinze morceaux
ce nivelage de mineurs et c'est sûr
mercredi on va faire une sacrée
bienvenue à michael le fils du cafetier
prisonniers des iraniens pendant 14 mois
et qui rentre à la maison
sur toutes les fenêtres sur toutes les
façades bienvenue michael on est fiers
de toi
mais la fête ce sera pour mercredi
aujourd'hui on en est encore au
recueillement dans ce petit village
d'immigrants russes dur travail et
fervent dans la prière pendant 14 mois
ans est agenouillé pour que dieu libère
l'enfant du village
aujourd'hui on prie encore pour
remercier dans la neige on a planté 52
drapeau est partout ces rubans qui
rappelle cette romance américaine écrite
par un prisonnier
si tu m'aimes toujours attache le ruban
jaune ana c'est sûr qu'on l'ait miquel
il est né ici dans ce qu'a fait michael
metering haut conseiller politique à
l'ambassade d'iran et ce matin ses
parents sans fanfare ni tambour on avait
tenu leur départ secret par des
prouesses pointe avec leurs deux valises
bouleversé de joie évidemment il passe
d'abord par washington devant la maison
blanche
quelle aventure et 1/2 long tenons bon
voyagistes et
dans le village quand ils reviendront
mercredi ce sera la fête majorettes
défilé parade en voiture les 5000
habitants seront là des pleurs des
embrassades
on s'est préparé comment a t'on vécu
cela ici cette vieille dame ukrainienne
nettoie une machine à coudre de 1878 la
machine est plus vieille que le village
j'étais seul chez moi les otages ont été
libérés dit elle je regardais la
télévision et ne cessez de pleurer le
coiffeur mercredi a promis de raser
gratis
les vidéos procès soit ans il était
temps dit il
comme nicole est allé à fait un gâteau
cailloux et elle me chercher pour mikel
canaris t il pu goûter ont maintenant
lui pour allouer lui seul le premier sur
les aéroports on devra embrasser madame
et ringo le prochain qu elle embrassera
ce sera son fils ensuite reggane on est
en bonne compagnie sur la valise du père
libérer les otages de l'autre côté
bienvenue à michael je n'ai changé
qu'une seule étiquette dit il en
souriant
en arabie saoudite à la mecque réunion
inaugurale de la troisième conférence au
sommet du monde islamique 700 millions
de musulmans de 37 pays sont représentés
par leurs dirigeants dont trois rois 5
émir evin président la porte sud de la
grande mosquée de la mecque la porte de
la paix a vu passer ce soir les
représentants de 700 millions de
musulmans
trente sept dirigeants de pays
islamiques comme le roi hussein de
jordanie l'un des trois souverain qui
participent à cette rencontre avec le
roi khaled d'arabie hassan ii du maroc
hussein est l'une des vedettes de ce
sommet
car depuis la création de la conférence
islamique en 69
après l'attentât contre la mosquée al
aqsa de jérusalem c'est toujours le
problème de l'occupation des lieux
saints de l'islam par israël qui
mobilise le monde musulman et ses hommes
qui représentent 60% du pétrole mondial
ont déjà décidé de nouvelles sanctions
économiques contre les pays qui
reconnaîtraient jérusalem capitale
d'israël
mais la oumma la communauté musulmane
est loin d'être unis l'iran a boudé le
sommet en raison de la présence de
l'irak la libye aussi le roi khaled
d'arabie traditionnellement gardien des
lieux saints de l'islam a demandé aux
pays musulmans de se consacrer à la
lutte pour la libération de jérusalem
les pays islamiques vont ainsi augmenter
leur soutien aux palestiniens de gaza
arafat qui recevront cette année
quelques 400 millions de dollars 2
milliards de francs
la syrie du général assad est appelée à
jouer un rôle de premier plan
car depuis que l'egypte a signé la paix
avec israël la résolution 242 le conseil
de sécurité n'est plus jugée valable par
le monde islamique pour régler le
conflit du proche orient
mais ces hommes sont loin d'être unie
divergences sur le soutien aux
palestiniens l'afghanistan le conflit en
irak iran
leur seul dénominateur commun c'est
finalement l'islam au club de la presse
d'europe numéro un ce soir le chemin de
perez que les sondages en israël désigne
comme le prochain premier ministre a
déclaré arabes et israéliens nous
n'avons d'autre choix que la paix il
faut maintenant trouver de meilleures
solutions pour mener à bien les
négociations avec l'egypte sur
l'autonomie en cisjordanie et à
après la grève en pologne r un
commentaire de l'agencé officielle
soviétique tassel dit en substance le
recours à la grève comme moyen de
pression sur le gouvernement polonais
est particulièrement inquiétant après
demain mardi à 20 heures reçu jusqu'à
destin répondra aux questions des
journalistes d'antenne 2 dans la série
une heure avec le président de la
république giscard d'estaing devrait
traiter essentiellement en matière
internationale
primo des relations est-ouest après
l'arrivée de ronald reagan à la maison
blanche
deuxièmement de la situation en afrique
troisièmement des suites de la crise
polonaise et rappelant que le président
a été la semaine dernière reçu par le
pape qui venait d'accorder audience à
lech walesa mais on abordera mardi dans
l'émission des sujets les plus divers
précisons qu'en ce qui concerne la levée
des sanctions économiques françaises qui
furent prises contre l'iran à cause de
l'affairé des otages
le gouvernement a souligné ne pas
vouloir précipiter les choses
le chef de l'état répondra jean pierre
elkabbach alain duhamel et georges
bortoli mardi à 20h et le journal
télévisé ce soir là sera avancé à 19h04
la semaine qui vient de se terminer a
été important ma campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle hier françois
mitterrand être déclarés candidats
officiels du ps au rpr il ya une
rencontre michel debré jacques chirac
qui en principe aurait dû rester
confidentielles mais qui finalement a
fait couler énormément d'encre
quant à monsieur marché il a durci son
ton à l'encontre du président de la
république mais le copain essayons de
faire le point et d'abord qu'est ce qui
est sûr et qu'est ce qui ne met pas tout
à fait bien effectivement il y a des
choses qui sont certaines et des choses
qui sont seulement probable et il ya
aussi il faut bien le reconnaître toute
une série d'interrogations
ce qui est certain en plus des
candidatures déjà connu de françois
mitterrand et de georges marchais c'est
le fait qu'il y aura deux candidats
gaulliste est ce qu est quasi-certain
aussi même si ça ne sera officielle
vraisemblablement qu'au début du mois de
mars
c'est la candidature de valérie giscard
d'estaing ce qu'éprouve la probable et
bien si l'on s'en tient aux sondages dit
bien imprudemment si on s'en tient
actuellement au sondage c'est que l'on
va vers une compétition entre valérie
giscard d'estaing et françois mitterrand
une compétition qui sera plus serré
qu'on ne pouvait le penser il ya
quelques mois encore tout se passe un
peu comme si après les fluctuations
d'une longue
période préélectorale chaque famille
française chaque famille politique
retrouvait son habituel audience et cela
est vrai semble-t-il aussi s'agissant de
l'électorat globalement de la majorité
et de l'électorat de gauche
voulez vous dire par là ne veut pas que
la situation est très semblable à ce que
les têtes ont 74
eh bien oui mais depuis 74 et évidemment
il y a eu un septennat et le bilan de
ses deux septennats va tenir une grande
place dans la bataille électorale est
depuis sans évoquer non plus
l'aggravation de la tension
internationale en restant strictement
sur le plan de la politique française
il y a eu la coupure de la majorité et
il ya eu la rupture de l'union de la
gauche
d'où la série d'interrogations que vous
utilisez l'est hé bien oui c'est lissant
de valéry giscard d'estaing je dirais
que l'on peut se demander s'il va
souffrir de ce que l'on appelle l'usure
du pouvoir ou s'il va bénéficier de ce
que l'on appelle la prime au sortant
comment va-t-il faire face à elle la
double surenchère anti giscardienne qui
va sans doute se développer entre les
deux candidats de gaulliste et également
entre les deux candidats de l'opposition
ces licences de françois mitterrand et
bien sa situation depuis la même qu'en
1974 il ne peut plus être accusée par la
majorité d'être le prisonnier des
communistes mais quelle proportion de
voix communistes va-t-il perdre deuxième
tour
et quelle proportion de voix gaulliste
pur at il gagné en bref valéry giscard
d'estaing va-t-il pouvoir renverser la
tendance qu'indiquent les sondages et
françois mitterrand qui bénéficie si je
puis dire actuellement négativement de
cette tendance pourra-t-il positivement
créer un mouvement en sa faveur qui lui
permettent de franchir la barre des 50%
telle est je crois l'enjeu est pour
l'emporter vous le savez les deux
candidats ont décidé de mener chacun une
campagne très courte
monsieur jacques baulin
secrétaire-général du parti républicain
a déclaré
les socialistes auraient pu faire
l'économie d'un congrès extraordinaire
pour mettre à l'ordinaire de la campagne
présidentielle
la rituelle candidature de françois
mitterrand letterman soupirant comment
peut-il parler continue monsieur jacques
blanc d'une autre politique celui qui
reste l'implacable et diabolique mais
l'épilateur d'un appareil construit pour
sa seule et unique ambition et qui reste
prisonnier d'un projet suicidaire et qui
reste toujours l'otage d'un pacte
démoniaque
fin de citation je paye un peu de ski à
france inter a souhaité que la campagne
des élections présidence
elle je cite pose des vrais problèmes
devant lesquelles nous nous trouvons on
ne vote pas peur des critiques et des
insultes en votes sur les propositions
il s'agit de savoir quel est le chemin
que l'on va prendre pour les sept années
qui viennent les écologistes ont une
plateforme politique brice lalonde
réunissait ce week end à paris le
conseil interrégional d'aujourd'hui
l'écologie et comité de soutien à sa
candidature à la présidence de la
république
au delà des revendications purement
écologique les amis de brice lalonde se
prononce dans cette plateforme pour la
réduction de la durée du temps de
travail et l'arrêt des ventes d'armes
par la france à l'étranger
excusez moi demain soir à 20h35 un carte
sur table exceptionnelle consacrée à
l'élection présidentielle pour la
première fois l'émission accueillera
successivement deux candidats déclarés
marie france garaud et le leader des
radicaux de gauche michel crépeau demain
soir lundi donc à 20h35 cartes sur table
aussitôt après le journal télévisé
monsieur masse adjoint au maire de
tourcoing s'est vu refuser le
renouvellement de sa carte de membre du
parti communiste il avait fait naître
une polémique au sein de son
organisation politique en déclarant
publiquement l'an passé qu'il condamnait
l'intervention soviétique en afghanistan
la section du pcf de tourcoing explique
que monsieur masse et non seulement en
désaccord avec son parti mais qu'il le
combat un attentat d'un genre nouveau a
été commis hier soir coûtant la vie à
monsieur durand conducteur d'un train de
voyageurs
aéroport de roissy gare du nord il a été
atteint par un bloc de béton d'une
quinzaine de kilos lancé d'un pont sous
lequel le train allait s'engager en
signe de protestation le trafic des
trains de banlieue est interrompue
aujourd'hui à la gare du nord et la
direction de la sncf ne peut pas dire
s'il sera assuré normalement demain père
marc marchetti s'est rendu sur les lieux
de cet attentat qui a été revendiqué par
le g et la groupe de libération armée de
laghouat la vitre brisée restitue la
dimension exacte du bloc de béton jeter
du haut du pont sur la motrice
le train roulait à 120 kilomètres heure
on imagine la puissance de l'impact et
la rapidité foudroyante du drame sur son
siège
le conducteur a reçu le bloc en pleine
poitrine
il est décédé peu après alors que le
train s'arrêtait par l'intervention
automatique des freins car le simple
relâchement de la pression des mains sur
les manettes de conduite déclenché le
freinage de sécurité ce soir on ne croit
plus guère à un attentat terroriste bien
que le groupe armé pour la libération de
la guadeloupe les revendiquer ce matin
la police parle d'un odieux méfaits sans
retenir encore aucune hypothèse sur ses
auteurs
c'est dur de ce pont routier qui enjambe
les voies que les malfaiteurs ont agi il
faisait nuit à 19h45 hier soir le bloc a
été jeté par dessus la rambarde avec
assez de force pour franchir la grille
horizontale de protection ils n'étaient
pas suspendus au bout d'une corde comme
on l'a cru d'abord tous les trains sont
arrêtées jusqu'à minuit un signe de
deuil et de protestation
la grève continuera peut-être demain la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français la csmf décide de signer la
convention médecin sécurité sociale tout
en maintenant ses critiques à l'égard de
ce texte
jusqu'à présent la csmf qui est
l'organisation la plus représentative du
corps médical avait refusé de signer cet
accord relatif aux honoraires des
médecins conventionnés est conclu il ya
cette main entre les caisses de sécurité
sociale et la fédération des médecins de
france minoritaire dans la profession
demain lundi va commencer la deuxième
semaine du procès des militants
autonomistes corses devant la cour de
sûreté de l'état
ils sont accusés d'être je vous le
rappelle les auteurs de la prise d'otage
à bastelica en janvier 80 très inculpé
dans la présence dans le box est sans
doute le symbole de la situation
actuelle comme il ya des procès qui sont
longs comme la bible on risque les jours
passant d'oublier que chaque page chaque
audience apporte un enseignement devant
les cinq juges de la cour de sûreté de
l'état
ils sont treize maintenant ces hommes
qui durant quatre jours il ya un an ont
inquiété préoccuper le pouvoir central
et qui aujourd'hui représentent un
problème politique très citoyen calme
père de famille employé commerçants
agriculteurs chômeurs en sommes des
français comme les autres tellement
comme les autres d'ailleurs qu'on se
demande pourquoi ils sont là eh bien ils
sont là ces hommes parce que ça ne va
pas en corse
et c'est là d'ailleurs qu'ils prennent
malgré leurs hésitations leurs
maladresses une dimension politique
c'est évident qu'au niveau du certains
corse des autres
alors on tenait comprenant compte des
passions du blocage des structures des
maladresses et d indifférence
on comprend pourquoi là-bas le plastique
répond aux plastiques comprendre cela ne
veut pas dire excusez ça veut dire ne
pas négliger le prix d'amérique à
vincennes a vu la victoire
particulièrement nette du deuxième
favori de la presse des perrières idéal
du gazeau qui a laissé ses adversaires
sur place d'un démarrage époustouflant
et le retour du premier favori joueurs
qui ne l'a jamais mis en péril
troisième la jument american classic à
louey autrement dit un tiercé 18 17 14
regardez-la club spécial à gauche jaune
et vert et là bas au deuxième plan
maintenant seul en pet idéal du gazeau
casaque bleue toque rose d en face il a
démarré les parties de rêver par
lefebvre à toute allure et il a creusé
le trou ce qui concevait qu il n était
pas complètement en forme parce que il
s'était préparé non pas sur l'hippodrome
de vincennes dans les construit par at
war mais chez lui dans la manche et qui
l'ont laissé partir
à son démarrage ont pu temps idéal de
gazon est un facteur exceptionnel
il sert paix dans sa normandie une santé
un influx nerveux indispensable loin du
bruit de paris il trop tôt ont ils
troquent beau la contre attaque de jorky
casaque verte
bref l'état john key s'est peut-être
laissé surprendre démarrage sera très
belle mais il ne pourra venir terminer
qu'à quelques mètres du gagnant le
cheval de monsieur morin confond ses
quelques rares détracteurs deuxième du
prix d'amérique il y a deux ans battue
l'an passé pour avoir mal mesuré son
effort idéal du gazeau gagne aujourd'hui
superbement et les vrais amateurs de
sport épices applaudiront
chaleureusement de performance de haute
qualité
deuxième choc qui le favori malheureux
qui trouvera des compensations troisième
place et que l'on est bien revenue une
merveilleuse victoire de ce trotteur
magnifique quête idéal de gaza 18 17 14
tel est le résultat du tiercé mais nous
n'avons pas encore des rapports
il y avait énormément de jeu m'a-t-on
dit et puis ce sont trois des quatre
fables
le gazon qui remporte enfin la victoire
qu'on attendait de lui
depuis il faut bien le dire deux ans le
20e salon de la navigation de plaisance
ferme ses portes demain soir au palais
du cnit à la défense
à la sortie ouest de paris en dix jours
trois cent cinquante mille personnes ont
eu l'occasion d'y aller rêver devant les
1300 bateaux exposés sur les stands
la plupart des constructeurs estiment
que c'est un bon salon il est vrai qu'on
y a eu l'impression que de nombreux
français n'étaient pas disposés à faire
des coupes sévères dans leur budget
loisirs malgré la situation économique
un bilan du salon en compagnie d'henri
galets et de socrate qui pour la
circonstance a revêtu son gilet de
sauvetage
- socrates basset parisien je me
contente surtout de la navigation
côtière particulièrement adapté à mon
faible tirant d'eau et je vous le dis
même avec un ordinateur ce n'est pas
chose facile que de choisir ici le
bateau de ses rêves
quel budget prévu d'attaquer
le minimum
40 et francophones
aujourd'hui
la croisière côtière et qui vagabondage
après diverses la question posée à
l'ordinateur longueur prix matières
utilisées
le choix est à faire entre trente
embarcations différentes au salon quand
on parle de crise cela dépend pour qui
les grosses vedettes celle qui dépensent
beaucoup d'essence et qui sont
immatriculés ensuite un panama se sont
très bien vendus les voiliers moyen de
150 milles 1 300 mille francs ont trouvé
acquéreurs il est vrai que les amateurs
de voile donc devant sont souvent prêts
à de gros sacrifices
par contre les pneumatiques avec moteur
hors-bord de faible cylindrée le plus
faible budget pour une approche
familiale de la mer ont été quelque peu
boudé oslo mais ici l'embarcation rennes
a encore été cette année la planche à
voile
de 2000 à 6000 feront plus de 80 modèles
étaient proposés aux fervents de la
voile libre des modèles très inégaux
d'ailleurs
malheureusement jusqu'à présent la
planche à voile normalement utilisé
disons 20 week-ends par an
c'est à dire à peu près 40 jours est une
planche qui a une longévité de moins de
3 ans nouveauté encore avec les premiers
multicoques familiaux la vitesse assurer
plus de 12 noeuds pour les petites
bourses
ainsi ce trimaran en plastique mangent
indémontable transportable derrière une
remorque et rapide sous toutes les
allures pavillon
ohé
presque tous les constructeurs pensait
que ce salon 80 serait catastrophique
cela n'a pas aidé le cas puisqu'il a été
enregistré 8 % d'entrées supplémentaires
par rapport aux salons 80 plus de 350
mille personnes
ce million et demi de français
pratiquent les bateaux contre vents et
marées quel que soit le prix de
l'essence les sacrifices au niveau des
sports de loisirs ne sont même pas pour
demain ce n'est pas secrète qui vous
contredira
merci sokolov la bande dessinée existe
maintenant depuis un demi siècle c'est
un mode d'expression qui prend une place
de plus en plus grande un golem se tient
jusqu'à ce soir le 8e salon
international de la bande dessinée comme
10 des amateurs et brillant orateur la
bd voici les commentaires de ph
j'entends de patrick estève nous sommes
pas en inde mais angoulême ses musiciens
illustre le thème principal du salon
l'espace sonore dans la bande dessinée
cinquante mille visiteurs sont venus ce
week end toute la france pour rencontrer
leurs auteurs préférés mais aussi pour
faire le point sur la bd une forme de
communication qui a bien évolué depuis
ses débuts après avoir été réservé aux
enfants ces histoires sont devenus du
domaine des adultes actuellement on
assiste à une véritable prolifération de
nouveaux titres et il devient quasiment
impossible de tout lier le lie à peu
près un album par jour c'est à dire à
peu près 400 et c'est ça représente un
chiffre d'affaires fantastique voyez
cette pile plus de 60 milliards de
centimes songez que certains titres
dépasse le million d'exemplaires
tintin astérix c'est assez fantastique
lorsqu'on réfléchit qu astérix a atteint
sur certains titres plus de deux
millions deux cent mille exemplaires et
par rapport au chiffre d'affaires de la
littérature traditionnelle nous sommes
nous dépassons nous dépassons le chiffre
de littérature générale de peut-être de
la moitié quintin tiré à 65 millions
d'exemplaires astérix à 60 millions
suivi de près par lucky luke et sylvain
et sylvette cette diffusion massive
entraîne une responsabilité de plus en
plus grande de la part des auteurs
surtout lorsqu'il s'adresse à la
jeunesse
je ne sais pas moi je me sens
responsable au début quand j'ai commencé
disons à des seniors bon je vais
dessiner ce que j'aimais dessiner
raconter les histoires mais lorsque j'ai
vu l'impact parmi les jeunes eux mêmes
parmi le corps professoral parmi
certaines analyses qui ont été faites je
me suis rendu compte que je ne pouvais
pas raconter non seulement des bêtises
mais que je ne pouvais pas non plus
manipuler mes lecteurs le jeunes
s'identifient aux héros si le héros est
beau il est bon il aimerait boucler ma
réponse si le héros et méchants
il trouvera un méchant c'était tout à
fait normal il va la pratique ailleurs
que cela plaise ou non la bande dessinée
devenu un mass média à part entière
détail amusant les éducateurs qui
étaient ses plus farouches opposants
sont venus ses plus fidèles partisans
depuis que les éditeurs présentent des
ouvrages à vocation historique et
scientifique
en fait la bd est un véhicule chacun pu
l'utiliser à sa guise le temps demain si
elle très nuageux à couvert nombreuses
brumes et brouillards principalement de
l'équipe vendée sur les régions
parisienne nord bourgogne sur l'est et
le centre dépôt de givre et verglas
attention quelques neige éparses sur le
jura la savoie l'après midi beaucoup de
nuages mais aussi des éclaircies surtout
dans l'ouest du pays au cours de la
journée temps clair et bien ensoleillé
près de la méditerranée
vent d'ouest à nord-ouest faible
températures en légère hausse dans l'est
en légère baisse dans l'ouest du pays
le dernier journal vous sera présenté
par gérard holtz en fin de programme je
pense qu'il aura les rapports du tiercé
demain antenne de midi avec daniel
bilalian qui aura comme invité michel
sardou demain soir vous retrouverez
patrick poivre d'arvor
bonsoir et 6